hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar the role
of interference gamma release
assay in the tb testing program
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar
is presented by labyrinths and brought
to you by diasorn
to learn more please visit theosorin.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speaker
marie claire rollinson
clia laboratory director and assistant
director at the bureau of
public health laboratory in jacksonville
florida
for a complete biography on our speaker
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
marie claire you may now begin your
presentation welcome
hello uh well thank you very much for uh
inviting me to speak today and i'm going
to talk about the role
of the interferon gamma release assay
in the tb testing program
the learning objectives today are to
review the role of igras in the
diagnosis of tb infection
summarize some recent changes in in agra
testing
focusing on guidelines associated with
agri-testing for certain populations and
then lastly
i'm going to discuss the implementation
of agra testing
in a public health program
if we look at tuberculosis in the u.s
the most recent report from cdc which
came out in march
of 2020 there were 8 920 new tb
cases in 2019 in the us and that's a tb
incidence of 2.7 cases per 100 000
persons
and a review of the data showed that the
rate of tb
among non-us born persons with 15.5
times higher
than in u.s born persons four states
contributed approximately half of all
u.s
cases including the state in which i am
florida which reported 558 cases
and although the number of cases did
continue to decrease it was a 1.1
decrease from 2018 the current trend
is not sufficient to reach the goal of
tb
elimination in the us
so what is that this goal of tb
elimination will tb
elimination would be fewer than one case
for one million persons
and as i said at the current rate
modeling does not predict the us
would reach this tb elimination goal in
the 21st century
or at least not without considerable
concerted efforts that would include
overall investing in programs that
identify test
and treat populations at high risk for
tb
but also focusing on populations at risk
for
latent tb infection ltbi
and investing in enhanced detection and
treatment
of latent tb infection
so today i'm going to focus on
latent tb infection and the importance
of detection of ltbi
approximately three to five percent of
the us population have
lpbi and without treat without treatment
five to ten percent of
healthy persons will
progress to tb disease in their lifetime
and this this percentage increases
substantially among
immune compromised patients with ltbi
including persons receiving
immunosuppressive therapy
or those who are immunosuppressed as a
result of a certain
underlying comorbidity or disease for
example uncontrolled hiv
and in tw in the cdc report from
2018 it highlighted nearly half of tb
cases in non-us-born persons were
diagnosed
greater than 10 years after arrival in
the us indicating that a lot of this tb
was reactivation of remotely acquired
ltbi
and in fact even though uh
half of these are detected greater
or they progress to tb disease at
greater than 10 years after arrival
of course many more of those cases are
also remotely
required and in fact it's estimated to
be
responsible for more than 80 percent of
domestic
active tb cases
as i said tb elimination will require
enhanced surveillance
detection and treatment and of course
i highlight their detections because
here the focus is laboratory diagnosis
and we can really see the key role that
the lab
is going to put play in tv elimination
and this is for ltbi among at-risk
populations so the populations
recommended
for focused efforts according to cdc and
the us preventive services task force
include persons who
currently live or previously lived in
congregate settings
persons born in or who frequently
travel to countries where tb is
prevalent
healthcare workers and others who work
in places where there's a high risk of
tb transmission
immunocompromised persons who have a
higher risk for developing tb
disease once infected and persons who
are contacts of a person
with infectious tb disease
and tb as we know is a preventable
disease
and prevention really starts with the
detection
and the diagnosis of ltbi
so let's have a look at some of the
diagnostic testing for ltbi
well the tuberculin skin test has been
around for
over a hundred years and this is the
detection of
cellular immune response it's the
administration of an intradermal
injection that
produces an immunological reaction to
mycobacterium tuberculosis
and this can be measured
by the skin's response and is read at 48
to 72 hours
after the injection one of the main
limitations
of the tuberculin skin test is that it's
not performed in a clinical or
laboratory setting
it and it relies on the interpretation
of the reader
it must be interpreted in conjunction
with the person's risk
and the tubercular skin test can
elucidate a non-specific reaction
for example in somebody who has been
vaccinated with the bcg vaccine or
there may be no reaction in certain
persons
for example hiv
positive and so the no reaction energy
could produce a false negative um
because there's an
inability for the skin to react um
and this may also happen if
the tb infection is very old or it may
happen
in persons who are very young
and there's also the
possibility for false positives with
this if someone has an infection with a
non-tuberculous microbacteria
like i said previous bcb bcg
vaccination and of course if the test is
not
operated correctly there could also be
issues
with false positives or false negatives
so the other method for diagnostic
testing for ltbi
which is still looking at a detection of
the cellular immune response
is a laboratory-based method
that um detects sensitization to mtb
by measuring release of interferon gamma
and in response to synthetic peptides
that represent specific mtb
proto proteins and these are
interferon gamma release assays and
require a blood draw from a person
um and like i said uh looks at
release of interferon gamma either
directly
interferon gamma or interferon gamma
producing cells that are then either
measured by
elisa or early spot there are also some
limitations
with agra there are fewer issues with
non-specific
reactions but an agra cannot distinguish
an old from a new infection
and it cannot be used to monitor
treatment
as with the tuberculin skin test the tst
there is pros possible
possibility for no reaction or energy
and a false negative
this may be if a person is severely
immune compromised
and and there are also some other
challenges with
eiger testing for example like i said it
requires a blood draw
and blood samples must be processed
within a certain time frame
after collection there can be errors in
the collection and transport of these
blood samples
and there's limited data on eye use of
ibrs for children
younger than the age of five persons who
are very recently exposed
to tb um immune immune comp
severely immune compromised persons and
also
the role of agra if they are used
serially
one of the other
disadvantages of igra is
it's more expensive for example than the
tst
so cost is also a factor
nevertheless there are many advantages
of
igra versus tst and i've just put up
a comparison of these
two methods which is part of the cdc
core curriculum
guidance
so the advantages of performing igra
as i highlighted it's a laboratory-based
test
and so with that there's the use of
positive and negative controls
objective results defined interpretive
criteria
and there's just a robust quality
assurance around
the entire process and there's the
opportunity to automate in the lab
setting
it's a single patient visit so unlike
the tst where
the injection is administered and then
read within 48-72 hours
this is a single blood draw for the
patient
results are also available quickly
within 24
hours or sometimes less
aggress are unaffected by bcg
vaccination
and there is no cross-reaction with the
majority of non-tuberculous mycobacteria
so next i'm going to talk about some
guidance
related to the use of agra some which is
quite recent but if we look at the
cdc guidelines published in 2010
they did state that agra could be used
instead of tst
to aid in the diagnosis of tb infection
and that it was preferred in persons who
were bcg
vaccinated and persons unlikely to
return
to have their tst red
these guidelines have recently
been updated a 2016 joint statement from
cdc the american thoracic society
and infectious disease society of
america instead
strongly recommended igor for all bcg
vaccinated persons and those
unlikely to return for the tst reading
and additionally
for those above the age of five with low
to intermediate risk of progression
regardless of bcg status or likelihood
of returning
if it does say in this statement
for uh persons under the age of five
agrees
on was acceptable but tst still prover
preferred and as i alluded to earlier
this is about
there being more limited data on this
age group for agra testing and its
performance
this joint statement or also said that
agra
or tst there was no preference in
individuals greater than five years of
age with
high risk of progression could be used
another recent change was in the civil
surge
guidance to civil surgeons and this is
for immigration testing
so since october 1st 2018 civil third
surgeons must use an igra for this
immigration testing in alignment with
cdc recommendations
so the tst is no longer an acceptable
test to be performed in this setting
and in may 2019 cdc
also updated guidelines regarding tb
screening and testing of health
care personnel by igra or tst
the the guidelines still state that
tb agra or tst should be
performed upon hire to get a baseline
for for the new employee but
i should also or tst should also be
performed if there is a known exposure
or
ongoing transmission at a healthcare
facility
and that agra or tst can be performed
annually
for certain groups who are at increased
occupational risk for tb
exposure i think one of the things to
highlight here
is that there's quite an emphasis on the
local jurisdiction and the healthcare
facility
to make the judgment upon when testing
should be performed for certain groups
at higher risk
in the document it mentions
pulmonologists and respiratory
therapists
laboratory personnel are not
specifically mentioned but i think
laboratory personnel performing testing
on tb would
fall into this category in the absence
of a risk
routine serial testing should not be
performed
so let's have a little bit uh of a look
at
um the igras that are available on the
market
there are two fda approved methods on
the market in the euro us
the quantiferon tb gold plus from kyogen
and this was first fda approved igra on
the market back in 2001
but has evolved since that time
and the t-spot tp from oxford
immunotech now quest diagnostics
and if we compare these two interferon
gamma release
assays you can see that there's slightly
different processes with the collection
and the detection so
[Music]
the collection process needs to be
adhered to in terms of timing
um there are slightly different um
antigens that they detect the qst gold
plus now
includes additional mhc-1 classes
and the two assays are measured slightly
differently
the quantiferon looks at interval and
gamma concentration whereas the t-spot
looks at the number of interferon
gamma-producing
cells and there are slightly different
ways of interpreting
the results there have been some recent
changes of note
with agra testing and i wanted to
address some of those
today specifically with the quantiferon
tb gold plus
this became available in the us in 2018
and the prior assay the quantifier on
golden tube was no longer available in
the us
after june 30 2018
the tb gold plus assay has four tubes
instead of the three tube setup for the
golden tube assay
and with the new tb gold plus assay
there's a
an addition of a tb2 tube so there
with the four tubes there's nil mitogen
tb1
and tb2 and the tbt 2 tube
also looks at cd8 t cell responses
so this assay's optimized for cd4
and cd8t cell response and has a
sensitivity greater than
94 and a specificity greater than 97
bd8 t-cells are an important component
of the host
immunity to mtb with studies showing
significantly higher cd8 t
cell responses in patients with smear
positive or active
pulmonary tb disease than in smear
negative or ltbi patients
and cd8 t-cell responses
are also identified in those who are
recently exposed contacts of patients
with active tb infection
the other
advantage of adding detection of cd8
t cell response is that patients
co-infected with tb and hiv
have been shown to maintain cd8 t-cell
responses
even though they may have low cd4 t cell
counts
so the addition of the tb2 tube and
inclusion
of these mhc class 1 peptides for the
stimulation of cd8 t
cell improves upon the sensitivity of
the assay to detect tb
infection both latent and active
and including infection as a result of
recent exposure
and in patients with immune compromising
conditions and potentially depleted cd4
t cell counts
another big change with the quantifier
on tb gold plus
assay is the option for a single tube
draw
this is drawn into a lithium
heparin tube and it has also
allowed for the processing time to be
from collection to
processing the lab extended to two days
so with the single tube drawer one ml of
blood
uh four ml of blood minimum is um
collected into the single tube and then
one mil
in the lab is transferred into each of
the four quantifier on plus tubes
and as with the prior quantifier on
assay
there are specific parameters around
timing
related to when the sample is collected
to when
it must be processed in the lab but with
the single tube drawer
it can now be refrigerated for up to 53
hours prior to transfer to the four
quantifier on plus
blood collection tubes which
is a good addition if samples are being
collected and potentially shipped
overnight for testing
and lastly there are new automated
solutions
which have greatly improved the
efficiency with which
agra can be performed here um
pictured here in our lab it's the
liaison quantifier on tb gold
plus assay and this is the instrument
that's from dsrn the liaison excel
and it's fully automated it's a
chemiluminescent analysis
it was recently fda approved
and it's 46 minutes to the first result
so it's has enabled full
automation efficiency accuracy
and enhanced throughput one of the other
things
of note here is the flexibility for
addition
other additional assays that can be
automated on this instrument
for example in our lab we most recently
have brought on the south kovi to igg
assay and the other
[Music]
advantage here as well is that the
instrument can be
interfaced so for efficiency purposes
the reporting of results straight into
our
limbs is a great benefit
so when we look at igra in the tb
testing algorithm
we can see that igrow is imp can play an
important role in detecting
ltbi as well as active tb disease
so agro testing is really part of a
robust algorithm for the lab diagnosis
of tb
that also still includes afb smear
culture
molecular diagnosis and antimicrobial
susceptibility testing
related to the diagnosis of active tb
disease
i've highlighted here a recent
publication
of the mycobacteriology practice
guidelines from the clinical
microbiology reviews
which is a comprehensive guide to
clinical microbacteriology testing and
does
include a section on [ __ ] as well
so if we summarize what we've talked
about so far
ltbi in the u.s i think
it's important to highlight that
targeting
ltbi is going to be necessary for the
elimination
of tb in the u.s and that
the lab and detection of ltbi
is going to play a significant role
non-u.s born
rates are not decreasing at the rate of
u.s born
and an estimated 82 of active tb cases
are a result of remotely acquired lp
remotely acquired tb and therefore
um we need to be detecting
that ltbi before these persons
get active tb disease there are shorter
safer
and more convenient ltbi treatment
regimens available
which hopefully will encourage people to
take treatment for ltbi
and the detection of ltbi can be
improved by the preferential use of agra
over tst in certain persons
lastly a most recent
update june 2020 cdc has provided a
summary of u.s
recommendations related to latent tb
infection
and it emphasizes that eliminating tb
requires expanded testing and treatment
of latent tb
and that testing for tb infection should
be a routine
and integral part of healthcare for
patients
with an increased risk
lastly let's switch gears a little bit
and talk about
the role of agra testing within a public
health
tb program and focusing
on florida department of health so
florida has
a system of tb care that ensures the
implementation
of core strategies of an effective
statewide tb program
treat to cure patients with active tb
protect close contacts to patients with
active tb
prevent future tb disease by identifying
treating
ltbi ensure infection prevention
practices are in place in facilities
where transmission
is likely if an individual with
undiagnosed tb disease is present
for example the homeless population
and correctional facilities
and to monitor and evaluate performance
to ensure that data-driven interventions
improve program outcomes
florida department health utilizes both
agra and
tst for the detection of lpbi either
tests may be used but certain situations
may favor one technique over the other
for the florida department of health
agree utilization has been
as part of the establishment of a
clinical diagnosis of tb disease
in contact investigations or outbreaks
of
public health importance
and monitoring of certain key
populations to rule out tb infection
for example the shelter card program
which i'm going to talk
a little bit about
to highlight the role of vigra within a
public health program
i'm going to talk about two examples
today one is with
our duval county health department and
the shelter card program as i just
mentioned
and then another initiative with
pinellas county health
department where there was an
investigation
of public health importance
so the duvall county health department
tb program
is part of the florida system of tb care
which ensures that clients with active
tb disease or latent tb infection
receive
consistently high quality care from
diagnosis to completion of treatment
through case management and patient
education
and coordination of local and state
resources so you can hear see here in
the slow diagram
when there is a suspect tb case
the important role of getting a
diagnosis for the
patient and care for the patient
and hopefully cure and also prevention
of
transmission
and patients with positive skin test or
aigra
and an abnormal chest x-ray or symptoms
of disease or risk factors for the
development of tb
disease are referred to the department
of health
duval county health department center
for specialized pulmonary services
and they really focus on monitoring
a specific patient's
latent tb infection and they include the
shelter car
program which is related to the homeless
shelters
the refugee program and jails and
prisons
they offer aggro testing as part of the
shelter car
program for any homeless person
seeking shelter in any of the four large
shelters in jacksonville
and the shelter's car program was
established in response to an
outbreak in the homeless population in
duval county
between 2004 and 2012.
and it has been an effective
surveillance
initiative that identifies tb disease in
persons visiting local
homeless shelters helps eliminate
transmission and reduces risk of
progression to active disease
with earlier detection of ltbi
and enables timely treatment
for those identified with ltbi
so this was some data uh from 2019
the number of clients that had been seen
at the shelter cart
as part of the shelter card program the
number of shelter card visits
number of aggress performed and then new
ltbis detected
and there was no persons who was
suspected
suspected of having active disease or
progressing to active disease
but you can certainly see that this
program was effective in identifying
ltbi
among this population and these are just
the
four shelters that you see on the bar
graph here
and um the percentage of clients testing
positive by shelter the highest
just over a little over five percent
um but like as i said um
this has been an important program in
identifying ltbi
and certainly identifying ltbi earlier
on to prevent
progression to disease for that person
and transmission to others
to support implementation of this
program the bureau of public health
laboratories in in florida implemented
uh igra testing specifically for the
shelter card
program and this was initially supported
by a grant
that enabled the public health lab to
support this important program
initially quantifier on golden tube was
implemented
and subsequently in 2018 the quantiferon
plus
we started out with the dynex ds2
which is a automated eia instrument
[Music]
which will hold two plates we switch to
a dynex agility
which has a higher capacity um
and i think the important thing to
highlight here
uh was that as part of this we
um we made sure we standardized the
reporting language and also reported
the testing results values as they were
useful for their health care providers
and overall implementation of igra in
the public health lab
reduced the indeterminate rate because
prior to this
all agras collected for the shelter car
program
were being sent to a commercial
laboratory for
testing it also improved turnaround time
and general overall quality improvement
and subsequently we are also about to
switch
to the dslr and liaison xl
as our instrument for testing
and here's uh the uh how are
the quantiferon gold plus results um
values look like and the interpretation
either positive negative or
indeterminate
and i've provided an example of
a report from our lab and this is a
a positive result that you can see there
and
just highlighting again the importance
of standardizing
reporting language so that
um clinicians can make
decisions based on these results
the department of health
investigation in pinellas county was
another
project where the public health
laboratory played a role
we wanted to be able to support a
contact investigation
and since often with these
investigations collection is in the
field
and collecting four tubes can be
challenging
prior to implementing the gold plus
um there had been
a preference to perform t-spot
instead um since that required only a
single collection
so with the single uh collection device
with the lithium heparin tube
uh the bureau of public health labs was
able to work with pinellas county
on this investigation
so there were actually three
investigations
uh in one there were
six positives in the second there
weren't there were none and in a third
there were two positives
so it was certainly helpful to use a
single tube drawer
for contact investigation purposes
and clearly can identify
additional persons who may have been
exposed
and for the lab we had to
obviously implement the single tube
drawer so there were some
changes that happened in the lab to
enable us to
be able to process the single tube
drawer because
the lab is then responsible for
aliquoting from that single tube
into the four quantifier on tubes we
actually
um purchased an automated pipetter to
prevent
errors and for ease of use
ergonomically you know when perpetting
from a single tube
into four multiple times
we also did a small validation of the
single tube drawer
and compared to the four tube drawer
with 10
patients and had a hundred percent
agreement
there were several advantages with this
outbreak
investigation for the single tube draw
and in general for any contact
investigations of public
health importance as i said the ease
with which
healthcare providers can collect samples
in the fee field
there's easier shipment with minimal
pre-analytical
steps and
the public health laboratory performs
the aliquoting and has greater control
over quality from a
from a pre-analytical
perspective so fewer indeterminate
results a lot of
uh indeterminate results with the
quantiferon assay
are usually due to errors in the
pre-analytic
pre-analytical process
this also enables maintaining of data
within the department of health for
surveillance processing
purposes
in summary utilization of igra is
recommended for certain populations
and has advantages over the tst skin
test
and utilization of agra in a public
health setting
has also improved testing for certain
patient populations
more rapid identification of latent tb
infection and linking to care and
treatment as appropriate
with the quantiferon plus assay the
single tube draw
has brought advantages to public health
for investigations of public health
importance and in certain patient
populations
for example homeless and prisons in jail
and i should also mention here the
addition of the tb2 tube
and the detection of the cd8 t
cell response has also brought
advantages with improved sensitivity
and ability to use this assay with
immune compromised
persons for example hiv positive persons
with potentially
lower cd4 t cell responses
and lastly implementation of eiger in a
public health setting
improves reporting for public health
surveillance
since agra and ltbi is not reportable
in most states and
i should also also finally mention
the importance to continue to think tb
i know that we're all in the middle of
the covid pandemic
and our focus is very much on covid
and detection of sarsko v2 and
because tb is a respiratory illness
there certainly could be confusion
over diagnosis or maybe delayed or
misdiagnoses
because of that and certainly
in in the state of florida we have had
a couple of cases where
uh covid was suspected but um
the south cov2 assays were
negative multiple times but
it was a week or two before
[Music]
a diagnosis of tb was established
so we must continue to think about tb
during this pandemic and reach our goal
of tb
elimination
so thank you very much for your
attention today i'd like to thank
my fellow staff at the bureau of public
health labs that worked
on this testing we work very closely
with the florida tb
program and specifically the project
with duval county health department and
pinellas county health department
thank you and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you marie claire for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left
of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
our first question is
how do you compare igra tests to tv
culture tests and pcr based
tests
agra tests are designed to detect
the cellular immune response to mtb
whereas tb culture tests and
any pcr tests are detecting actual
tb organism in a specimen so
the target of what it is testing is
slightly different
and agra can be used to detect
ltbi so latent tb infection in addition
to
being able to detect active tb disease
when we would use culture and pcr
we're really using that to detect active
tb disease
great thank you okay your next question
what is the florida health department
experience
using serial agra igra excuse me
sampling of individuals whose first
agra test is positive and a second
sample collected within the following
month
is negative
so within the florida department of
health we
sort of try to adhere to the
recommendations and not really perform
serial sampling
in this manner um however it does
sometimes happen that a person
gets two tests within a short period of
time and we get discordant results
and that's really when uh you know the
tb
program and tb medical director get
involved and look at the clinical
picture to determine
the next steps i think we know that with
agra especially with serial
testing you can get test variability
and so so that's why serial sampling is
not really
recommended as well as using agra
to monitor treatment
now your next question has a couple
parts to it and it says at what stage
can a person be infectious regarding tb
besides active tb patients can someone
with latent tb
transmit the microbacterium to others
who come in contact with him
so no with latent tb infection this is
an inactive phase of infection
and therefore
somebody with ltbi is not transmitting
disease however
the challenge with latent tb infection
is that it can progress to active
disease and once it has progressed to
active disease
then that person is capable of
of transmitting tb um and i think that
you know sort of highlights what uh i
was talking about at the beginning of
the presentation
about how we can really prevent a lot of
tb transmission by detecting and
treating
latent tb infections so that those
persons do not progress to
active disease and have the capability
to
transmit
great thank you now are there more
techniques that are being developed to
detect
ltbi one that is affordable so that
developing countries can benefit from
it
so i'm sure there are people working on
techniques to
develop maybe cheaper and and
easier to use rapid diagnostics
but i'm not really involved in
that's what i can't speak to any of that
i do
know that of course the expense
of agro is a drawback of the assay and
of course it
you know it's being done in a laboratory
setting with all the quality
parameters in place so certainly it does
uh add
an expense to the test
do you think tb screenings should be
conducted
on college campuses where students from
all around the world are in close
contact
so my understanding from the
recommendations
is that
widespread screening at college campuses
isn't recommended
um i think the recommendations for
screening
are really looking at persons who are at
high risk um from it coming from
countries where the risk of tb is
increased
um so i like i said i don't think um
it really supports screening of all
students where the majority of them are
going to be
at low risk but certainly identifying
those high risk
persons and getting
them tested would be key
great thank you okay your next question
how were the single tubes kept in the
field
once blood was drawn in the cooler
fridge for example
yes for our single tube drawers we
recommend
collecting and placing in a cooler and
with the projects that we had with
pinellas
county which required them shipping
fedex overnight to us
they shipped on cold packs but that
seemed to
be okay in the the florida heat we
didn't have
any issues with our pre-analytical
part of the assay there so it was a
pretty easy process
thank you now i see this question
popping up quite often
a lot of users want to know if your
slide deck will be available
and it will be so just to let everyone
know in the audience
if you um join the webcast following the
live broadcast come back into the studio
and there will be a link for you to
download the slide
within the studio okay now let's go
ahead and move on
to our next question do you see
many patients who flip flop around the
cutoff
so we have not seen that a lot because
of the
patient population that we have been
testing
based on the um two
initiatives that i mentioned in my
presentation
working with two of our uh county health
departments
so one population there was the
this um shelter card program with the
homeless population and we know that the
homeless population is at greater risk
and then the um the other cohort with
pinellas county
health department was specifically
related to an exposure and a contact
investigation
so the patients we're looking at
are at a higher risk and so we haven't
really seen that flip flop where
people talk about that wobble has been
with
health care providers um that
are tested on some sort of regular basis
and sort of seem to waver around the cut
off and be
positive one time and negative another
but we haven't haven't really seen it
now for this next question it says are
you aware
of an increase of new cases during this
coronavirus pandemic
um if anything we have
actually seen a decrease and
i would say that our
number our volume of samples coming into
the lab
is uh between 50 and 60 percent
of what it was this time last year and
i really think that is because people
are not coming into the tb clinics to
get
tested but we also know that people have
been
um staying at home and staying in
lockdown so it's
time is really going to tell what
impact um covid has on
uh pb testing will there be
persons with tb with a misdiagnosis
because they haven't accessed care
will there be additional transmission
um i i mean i think we don't know the
answer to some of those questions and
it's it's
you know as i said time is going to tell
i what i
obviously you know said at the end of my
presentation is
you know this importance with uh
educating
our healthcare providers to continue to
consider tb specifically in high-risk
populations because it is a resp
in many times with obviously with
pulmonary tb it is a respiratory illness
there can be some similar
symptoms between covid and tb infection
and so maintaining tb on that
differential diagnosis for patients will
be
essential
okay we have time for just a few more
questions and your next question says
will agra be able to detect the immune
complexes
in immunocompromised or immunosuppressed
patients as they are more susceptible to
tb
sorry can you repeat the question of
course
will agra be able to detect the immune
complexes
in immunocompromised or immunosuppressed
patients
so um aigra the current
formulations of agra both the t-spot and
the quantoferon gold class can
detect interferon gamma in both
immune competent
and immune compromised patients so yes
there
are obviously going to be some cases
which i did discuss a little bit in my
presentation of energy uh where you may
get a false negative
in severely immune compromised persons
who
are not eliciting a t cell response at
all
great thank you okay this audience
member wants to know which
pre-analytical system do you use
i'm not sure i'm clear
on the question um
but obviously you know in terms of the
pre-analytical process and i talked
a little bit about the that's where
errors can occur that can lead to
indeterminate rates
um so obviously
following the pre-analytical steps of
the protocol
very clearly is important and that's
we actually monitor our pre-analytical
process
based on our indeterminate rate so our
indeterminate rate really
informs us as to whether the
pre-analytical process
is being performed um
appropriately or not and i did see a
question and i can so i can just answer
it quickly that said what's that
indeterminate rate
and it's below 0.5 percent so it's
really low
um but that also comes with a lot of
outreach and training and because it is
working very closely with our county
health departments
we've been fortunate in that we have
mitigated a lot of those pre-analytical
issues
that can occur
thank you so much marie claire we have
so many great questions
and any questions that we do not get to
today will be addressed via the speaker
um via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
so let's go ahead and move on to your
final question did you have one
specifically marie claire here in the
queue that you would like
to answer so just ask the next one
i know we have a lot yeah you could just
ask the next one
okay great all right so let's see
okay would you recommend using qtf
over t-spot assay and why
so i mean i i can't really recommend one
over another i just have our experience
of using the quantiferon
and can just say that we um
like using the quantiferon gold plus
product
um because um we can
automate it in the laboratory um
it talked a little bit about you know we
perform it on
the agility which automates the eia but
now with
options total totally automated options
like the liaison excel
i think there are certainly advantages
to um
the quantifier on assay in those terms
and now with the single tube drawer
that's also
an advantage um that the quantiferon tb
golden tube assay did not have
because the teeth spot was a single draw
and
one of the other um great things about
the plus is having the tb1 and the tb2
tube
now so that it's detecting um
cd4 t-cell and cd8 t-cell
responses so an improved sensitivity to
that assay
thank you so much and marie claire do
you have any final comments
for our audience before we go today
no thank you everyone for your attention
and your questions and any questions
that um
i haven't been able to answer today i'd
be happy to
answer offline by email
thank you again for your time today in
your important work in public health
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor via foreign for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
again as a reminder any questions we did
not have time for today
and those that are submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by marie claire via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labrets will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye